hey 42 here 99% of people delete their
entire password and start over if they
mess up just one letter
welcome to riff Buckingham Palace has
602 rooms the largest sperm bank in the
world does not accept donations from
redheads because of insufficient demand
Facebook founder Mark Zuckerberg only
eats meat from animals that he has
killed himself Reno Nevada is farther
west than Los Angeles California
Sigurd the mighty a 9th century Norse
Earl of Orkney was killed by an enemy he
had beheaded several hours earlier he
tied the man's head to his horse's
saddle but whilst riding home one of its
protruding teeth grazed his leg he later
died from the infection insects
outnumber humans 100 million to one a
blue whale's heart only beats 9 times
per minute some fruit flies are
genetically resistant to getting drunk
but only if they have an inactive
version of a gene that scientists have
named happy hour Americans spend more on
dog food every year than they spend on
baby food when male fruit flies are
given alcohol they develop homosexual
tendencies your body paralyzes itself
when you sleep to keep you from acting
out your dreams st. George is the patron
saint of England leprosy and syphilis
hair is made from the same substance as
fingernails when Columbus apparently
discovered the new world there were at
least 50 million people living in the
Americas thanks for the view subscribe
for more thoughty2